what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so Mac for actions immortal iron fist is
amazing and this is one of those
instances where a character in Marvel
Comics gets like a wholesale relaunch
and that happens they come in books in
general from time to time like a person
pops up on the scene in the 1970s 1980s
they're just kind of considered a
low-level Street kind of character and
nobody really cares that much about them
and then somewhere along the line a
writer comes up and then just changes
everything like Geoff Johns did it with
green lantern right I mean for decades
Hal Jordan was a hero that no one cared
about his stories were not sewing you
could hardly ever sell a house wooden
sword even got rid of him and replaced
him with with Kyle Rayner
but then Geoff Johns came along and just
revamped the entire mythos and it
changed everything about the entirety of
the Green Lantern's line of stories
going forward because what it did is it
made them wildly interesting it made
them really intriguing it said the
character of Sinestro and turned him
from a orga typical villain who's just
there to try to make life rough for Hal
Jordan and turn him into a really really
cool and charismatic bad guy and so what
happened with Matt fractions immortal
iron fist if he did the exact same thing
with Danny ran Danny ran first showed up
in the 1970s he was a street-level
character they killed him off by having
a punch through a wall I mean he was a
totally irrelevant guy I mean he would
show up for time to time but if there
was never an instance where I would sit
down and say yeah man iron fist has one
of the richest legacies in the history
of Marvel Comics he was not the x-man he
was not the Avengers he wasn't in
Captain America he wasn't even iron man
he was just a guy who was there but what
Matt Fraction story does is it changes
all that and it makes iron fist
extremely cool so the cool thing about
this is that that Matt Fraction is kind
of grabbing a few things here and there
from the Iron Fist mythos but for the
most part he's just making things up on
the spot and it actually works out
really really well but what just does is
it basically picks up with iron fist
facing off against a legion of Hydra
like a legion of Hydra forces I mean
just just Stacy off against every last
one of them now we don't know why that's
happening what we do is we actually
transition back to earlier in the day
and what we end up finding out is that
there is a Chinese company that's
basically wanting to get involved with
Rand rant with Daniel and
company there we go let's go ahead
incorporated the idea is to basically
use R and incorporate as resources in
order to bolster what it is it's going
on with regards to China specifically to
basically get involved with funding like
a transportation track like a train
track or something along those line but
the idea that this company is willing to
invest 10 billion dollars to do it
Daniel Rand says no Danny Rand says no
and the reason why he says no is because
of the fact that China has a terrible
human rights record and Danny Rand does
not want to be involved with why go
industries because of China's human
rights record and so with this in mind
why go industries more or less just kind
of walks away and says you are a fool
for throwing away ten and a half billion
dollars and even jaren you know even
jeryn hogarth is it's kind of the same
mind I keep in mind here in Hogarth is
basically the brains behind the
operation I mean a Netflix jeryn hogarth
is actually a woman but in the comics
you know jeryn hogarth is kind of the
brains behind the operation keeping the
company running so it's very much the
sort of Pepper Potts Tony Stark
dichotomy right like Pepper Potts is the
one that keeps a company in working
order Tony Stark just spends money and
that's really what Daniel ran does what
he kind of focuses on being a superhero
but his suspicions are that why go
Industries is a front and that why go
Industries is operating as a legitimate
arm for Hydra now of course this takes
Danny Rand to the why go Industries
headquarters only to find out - the
building is literally just a ghost
building I mean it's totally phantom I
mean there's desks or circus heaters but
no one works there it's designed for
show now something to point out here in
Marvel Comics is that a lot of
organizations do this like Hydra doesn't
secret Empire did it back in the
nineteen seventies 1980s advanced idea
mechanics doesn't a lot of these
clandestine organizations operate
through like shell companies or they
operate using legitimate front end were
to carry out their goals and really what
seem to be going on here with regards to
- Daniel Rand or at least to Rand Rand
industries was that why go Industries
was wanting to use Daniel rands company
as money laundering in a sense but they
would basically flow money through Danny
rands company and then it would come out
clean on the other side and there'd be
no way to trace where it was that why go
Industries money was coming from in the
first place but regardless of what their
intentions were Danny ran suspicions
proved to be right and the simply he's
confronted by the entirety of Hydra this
is kind of cool because what this does
is it kind of shows us for Danny Rand
stands right like when it comes to
individual people when it comes to
normal individuals Danny Rand can easily
run right over them and then we have AI
this thing called a mecha Gorgon and
this is designed to kind of is
really Matt Fraction controlling with
Hydra like Hydra is just one of these
holdovers from old-school marvel comics
but their stories are always kind of
really fun in the sense that it was like
here's an organization that's somewhat
serious but also kind of silly I mean
they have a mecha Gorgon for crying out
loud like I mean it's clearly something
this is going to be a bit of a joke but
it's also kind of cool because Danny
grant can't necessarily take this thing
out on its own because it doesn't really
possess the power to do it on his own
and so again he's more or less kind of
knocked off this roof and it seems like
you know it's probably the end of Danny
ran so much as the fact that he's
temporarily defeated but what we do here
is we transition to what looks like an
opium den and this opium den is being
occupied by a guy named Orson Randall
now the cool thing about this is that
Orson Randall of course you after the
whole experience more or less returns
home but when he does there are a couple
of girls that show up at his door saying
you know our sister and I have come to
ease your you know to make life easier
on you use your imagination
and then Orson Randall kind of fights
off against the two of them but he
demonstrates use of the iron fist and
when he asked these girls who they are
where they came from they turn into
swans and they fly away and so this is
my fraction kind of messing with it
saying hey look there's some big things
going on here so what this does is it
sets Danny Rand and it sets Orson
Randall on a collision course in the
sense that Orson Randall basically
leaves from where he's at and begins the
process of trying to track down Danny
ran now again with regards to Danny
going against these Hydra forces in the
end he's basically rescued by Luke Cage
we don't really know exactly how he does
it but he's rescued by Luke Cage and
he's basically taken to night nurse now
with regards to Marvel Comics those are
guys who are not well versed in this I
know a lot of you guys have no
experience with regards to watching
Netflix and learning about Rosario
Dawson's Lite nurse what you see in
Netflix is par for the course when it
comes to night nurse there's been a few
different iterations of night nurse but
at the end of the day the role is always
still very much the same in the sense
that night nurse is basically a nurse
that takes care of superheroes who have
injuries and so on and so forth so they
don't have to go to a normal Hospital
the reason being because Danny Rand
wouldn't want to take off his mask at a
hospital and people find out that the
head of Rann Industries is a superhero
operating at night but what this also
does is it shows the relationship
between Luke Cage and Danny Rand and
that's really something that a lot of
people we're looking for in the Iron
Fist TV show or at least what they're
going to be looking for is something a
can or something tying in to the notion
of iron fist and Luke Cage because these
two have an extremely long and history
of Marvel Comics in fact
you can probably go watch my video on
Luke Cage Luke Cage explains because
that really runs over a lot of the
history between himself and Iron Fist it
was really just pairing together two
superheroes who's coming from or selling
and it actually led to one of the most
entertaining comic book runs regarding
the two characters because it just
worked it was a great blend of action
and comedy and even what's what's going
on right now and all-new all-different
marvel with Power Man and Iron Fist
is really really funny the problem is I
did a videos on it nobody cares so it's
one of those one of those comics I just
kind of read for my own enjoyment but
it's still a really enjoyable line of
publication
but what we're also shown here is that
misty Knight that Colleen wing and so on
they've created their own Heroes for
Hire now I wanted to wait until this
section of the story to cover this but
immortal iron fist takes place in the
aftermath of Civil War and that's one of
the reasons why Danny Rand went to night
nurse because if he had gone to a public
hospital even if he was willing to give
up his identity he would be arrested
because remember in the aftermath of
civil war like Tony Stark's team won
like the bad guys won so to speak so
registration is the law you have to
register your identity you have to
register your powers so on and so forth
with shield and the federal government
if you don't then you'll be taken into
custody but during the Civil War Civil
War videos that I did if you remember
Miss Lee Knight had launched her own
Heroes for Hire now the Reformation of
Heroes for Hire under misty Knight just
served the purpose of Marvel you know
just kind of bringing the team together
so the 20 Stark would have a way to find
Captain America because u.s. he was
operating underground and misty nice
contacts misty nice resources would have
allowed her to locate Captain America so
it was a really great way to blend these
upper echelon superheroes with the
street-level superheroes but again this
is really just kind of reminding us what
the environments like right now that
Iron Fist Danny ran can't just go out
into the world at any rain can just go
to normal places operating as iron
sister gets you'll be arrested by shield
if he does now from here we pick back up
with Orson Randall and Orson Randall is
really kind of cool here because using
iron fists what he does is he shows us
maneuvers that we've never really seen
before for example he uses the iron fist
in a way that basically hypnotizes a guy
as working randall is making his way
into the US and he's asked by the TSA
like we need your passport lead your
claims document declaration he says he
uses this kind of you know hypnotic
movement and then it's just kind of
allowed to go free and so again it
creates a really cool situation here
because it's this constant expansion on
what it is that's going on with regards
to the iron fist mythos but in terms of
the
a huge change that Matt Fraction made
this comes in the form of Jaron meeting
with Danny Rand and what happens as
Jaron says look where you turned down
why go industries and he said you don't
want to have anything to do with them
what seems to be happening is a hostile
takeover now what that usually means is
that if you have a company that's
publicly traded which means that you can
buy shares on the stock market what why
go Industries is doing is basically
going through and buying a majority
stake and Rand industries which means
that in terms of controlling the company
they'll be the ones running the show and
Danny Rand will basically be the small
man or you have the minority shares of
the company but in the midst of all this
information that Danny Rand is getting
his hand just starts to flare up and the
reason why is because Orson Randall is
using the iron fist technique and this
is cool because what this tells us is
that we're the traditional school of
thought would have been that Danny Rand
being the iron fist meant that he had
the entirety of the you know the hardest
shoe allows energy to himself instead
it's not that way that there are
multiple people who can tap into this
and multiple people can use it but what
it also means is that if two individuals
use the iron fist at the same time it
creates this sort of energy feedback in
the one who's not using it the crazy
Ozone kind of a physical pain so again
it's really Matt Fraction just kind of
building on the mythos and expanding
things and it's even Danny Rand himself
coming to the realization that someone
else is using the iron fist now when
Danny rands mind that shouldn't be
possible because there's only ever
allowed to be one iron fist at a time
now the reason why you know combining
what we're seeing here along with
traditional knowledge on the iron fist
mythos the reason why was only ever
allowed to be one iron fist at a time is
because that we basically have two
people splitting the power in half and
so Danny Rand has the power of the iron
fist but so does Orson Randall and what
his situation presents to us as the idea
that Danny Rand never had the full
content of the island fist unto himself
instead he was always sharing it with
Orson Randall whether he knew it or not
it sort of creates this really really
interesting situation because it begs
the question but what would happen if
Danny Rand had the full power of the
iron fist and so what this does is the
transition to Y go industries power
picks up with a guy by the name of steel
serpent also known as Davos now Davos
publication history and Marvel Comics
was the very definition of an irrelevant
villain he had always faced off against
Danny ran he had always gone against him
as an enemy
this oldest paused but it was always
like a holdover it was always a sort of
archaic villain where was like this
stereotypical guy like well I'm going to
get you this time Danny ran it was
always that way
what Matt Fraction is doing is coming
back and saying no that's not the case
that brother Davos said that steel
serpent is a very formidable villain er
he's a formidable bad guy of course
being the son of lei kun the Kandra lake
lake hoon the Thunderer there we go
that's what a mouthful the other guy the
trained an ear and in order to basically
conquer Xu lei the dragon and attain the
heart of the Dragon allowing him to have
the the iron fist what this does is it
sort of updates the rivalry between
Danny Rand and and dabblers to a more
modern sense in a more modern way and so
ultimately what this does is it kind of
brings again
Orson Randall and Danny Rand in a
conflict when what with one another when
Orson Randall basically buys a guy's
suit and then shows up at Rand
industries in the office of Danny and
the two of them start going head-to-head
and the funny thing about this is that
it seems as though when it comes to like
fighting styles when it when it comes to
just use of the iron fist that
experience is the key to success Danny
Rand has been an iron fist for quite
some time but he's not been an iron fist
anywhere near as long as Orson Randall
has and so on the surface it seems like
Danny Rand is basically being totally
overcome and getting absolutely crushed
but in the end he actually ends up
coming out or at least holding his own
against Orson Randall not only that
Orson Randall basically says you know
look you look nothing like your father
which is not fracturing revealing to us
that Orson Randall taught Danny rands
father which basically bolsters the
mythos of his dad because all we really
knew about Danny rands father was the
fact that he ran a company he was
betrayed by a friend his father was
looking for looking for the mystical
city of Kunlun died in the process and
then Danny Rand was discovered by some
of the monks within Kunlun and then went
on to become iron fist that was all we
knew there was virtually nothing to it
because his father served as a catalyst
it serves as part of a hero's journey
where the characters just kind of thrust
him to adventure Danny Rand lost his
father his mother was eaten by wolves he
was discovered by monks the Iron Fist
legacy begins that was it and so Chris
really this this interesting situation
what we also end up finding out here is
with regards to the iron fist mythos
that there's been about 60 some-odd
people before Danny Rand who called
themselves the iron fist not only that
the reason why it worsened Randle is
basically being pursued is because of
the fact that what's coming up is
something called for the tournament of
the seven heavenly cities and again
this is a really cool thing because this
is a huge expansion to the Iron Fist
mythos one of the reasons why I love it
so much but transitioning back to Davos
for a second what he is is essentially a
kind of adopted character adopted son so
to speak and the sense that he's
basically a guy who is borrowing power
that's really all he's doing he's not
like really iron fist he's not really
able to tap into the energies of Sheela
or any other kind of mystical energies
instead these energies are basically
being loaned to him now in terms of how
we'll find that out of course well we'll
get to that here in a second but what
this does is it sort of thickens apart a
little bit and of course it picks up
with jarran and all it's really
happening here is the head of LIGO
Industries is more or less telling Jaron
you're going to basically give us what
it is we're asking for from Rand
industries or we're going to kill your
mom that's not best really it that's
really all that's going on but what this
does is it transitions back to Davos and
it joins with Queen Mother now this is
where things begin to expand a little
bit because again what's happening here
is Davos is getting its energy from
crane mother and Davos is being tasked
with killing Orson Randall now there's
one this matters is because we sort of
jumped back to 1933 and we basically
meet up with the heads of these seven
heavenly cities and what goes on is
every once in a while there's a
tournament where these cities all
basically align with one another and the
tournament ends up seeing the different
individual cities version of Iron Fist
the immortal immortal warriors basically
what they're called but they all face
off against one another in the
tournament to see which one is the best
of all the cities the issue with this is
that Orson Randall refused to
participate because of the fact that he
had basically fled who in loon and in
doing so became embroiled in part of
World War one and all the death and
destruction that he saw he lost his
taste for battle and for war and so when
the time came when he was supposed to
fight on behalf of Kunlun he said no he
basically ran away the judgment of the
council under the direction at least
under the the prodding of crane mother
was that Orson Randall would be stripped
of his position as iron fist and in turn
a new one would be appointed and so one
of them happening here is you basically
learned that the reason why Davos is
operating as an agent from other crane
is because of the fact that when the
sentence was implemented against Orson
Randall and when he was basically
pursued by plain mothers agent you know
her her immortal weapon that worsened
Randall had killed that an immortal
weapon and fled Kunlun and so ever since
then my mother is wretchedly sworn a
vendetta against Orson
and all to basically bring his bring his
life to an end the reason why is because
of the fact that crane mother can only
give birth to an immortal weapon every
300 years now what this shows us is that
the different heavenly cities Kunlun and
all these other heavenly cities have
their own variants by bringing about
their immortal weapons we're Kunlun
basically has a particular person fight
you allow the dragon and if they defeat
the dragon immerse their fists in the
dragon's molten heart and access to the
the iron fist energies what other cities
do is like they'll give birth to their
immortal weapons and those immortal
weapons will have all the same kind of
powers and all the same kind abilities
that are similar to iron fist but it
basically kind of rooted in that own
individual city so what ended up
happening is because of the fact that
Orson Randall killed the immortal weapon
of crane mother she's basically gone to
Davos and says we will give you whatever
it is that you need whatever kind of
training you need or whatever kind of
energy you need or whatever life
whatever it is that you need in order to
make yourself a weapon that can kill
Orson Randall we will give that to you
you will serve your purpose and then you
will fight alongside us in the
tournament of the seven heavenly cities
and so again this is really kind of cool
because what this does is it basically
has Danny Rand and Orson Randall heading
back to Rand industries after everything
that's been going on so far but when
they arrive there they're met with Davos
and this is really just sort of a Matt
Fraction kind of wrapping up all
loosened simply saying that we're or
Singh Randall is here he can't afford to
be here that it's easier to somebody
just get rid of Orson Randall and let
Ironfist Danny Rand sort of continue on
from there and that's really exactly
what happens I mean where they're facing
off against these Hydra agents where
jeryn hogarth had taken off to meet the
Heroes for Hire to tell them what's
going on and he's attack you know
they're all attacked by various Hydra
agents what this does is it basically
sees the death of Orson Randall Orson
Randall is effectively killed by Davos
now of course Davos immediately turns a
slice to Danny Rand
right I mean actually how it is that
they're just mortal enemies Davos will
take any opportunity to face off against
Danny Rand and this is an opportunity
that's granted to him the difference
here is that with the death of Orson
Randall Danny Rand village is kind of
like plunges his heart in Orson's chat
and draws on the full energies that
basically exist for the iron fist
technique and so because of this Danny
rands basically a full power now and
again what is happening is he basically
overpowers Davos in the extreme analysis
cannot keep up and so what happens is a
Davos basically retreats and
operation under the guise religious says
the tournament of the seven heavenly
cities is coming and when it does we
will fight on even ground and when we do
all proved to be the one that's on top
here and so of course what the starts is
wrapped up pretty fast with regard to
the fact that we're Danny Way and
intends to basically kill one of the
members of Hydra that in the end we
basically have a UT of course against
the leader of Kunlun alongside lay crew
the lake during the Thunderer the
trainer of Danny ran show up and say the
tournament of the seven heavenly cities
is starting you have to come with us and
you have to participate in this
tournament now at this point if I
remember correctly and all could have
swear this but if I remember correctly
Matt Fraction or maybe was some other
riders released a series of one shots
that covers some of the other members of
the either of the iron fists that a bit
of carry the mantle of iron fists or or
operating as part of the seven heavenly
cities but it really kind of cool one
shots are pretty interesting but this
goes into the tournament of seven
heavenly cities and it thank you pretty
cool to see but again I mean this this
one was only twenty four issues long it
was pretty short feel it's four or five
videos in total but if you guys are new
here to come this explained wish you
guys did to sub button to become part of
the rival Court you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later please
[Music]